hey did you catch the um Piers Morgan
Andrew take I did I actually just
finished listening to it this morning
because there were some clips that were
going around and then the full interview
dropped from what I could see this
morning so I just wrapped up listening
to it like half an hour ago what'd you
think
I mean exactly what I expected
um Tate was calm and cool and collected
for the most part I mean it really
reminded me a lot of conversations that
I have on stereo with people that come
in with a implicit bias and they already
don't like me or what I have to say and
they want to take things out of context
and the interrupting thing it's it's
just crazy
and was off the chart it's crazy he
showed him and especially for a guy like
Piers Morgan who's been who people would
say is a little more based than most
because of his show and he usually takes
the villain side and he's been I think
he got kicked off or he had to resign
from one morning show that he had to
leave yeah to leave the morning show
um he got into the whole trans debate
and stuff like that but it's really
interesting that he was kind of taking
that side now of saying you know in this
obsession with
are you sorry do you apologize right do
you regret it and it's just is this what
it's all about it seems like the first
30 minutes they were just going around
in circles about nothing
um so hats off the Tate I mean the guy
is a Class Act in every interview every
interaction that he does he knows
exactly what he's doing he's incredibly
smart incredibly intelligent and knows
his way around a microphone so
um I get it man it's it's tough to sit
there and have to take that kind of
stuff from people that you could smash
so easily
um when and and that's the only thing
separating you is a is a desk and some
some papers
um but you know I think the more
it's been great for him and the more he
can get out there and get in front of
people the people that are going to hear
what he says and they're going to agree
and even though this whole thing had
this implicit bias against him I think
it's only going to be a net positive
yeah I mean he like uh Morgan came at
him pretty hard there was a few areas
where I was I had the expectation that
Andrew would hold firm on points
um for example uh marriage you know uh
Morgan asked him if he would ever get
married and he was uh I think he implied
that he would
um but he in the past another podcast
was vehemently opposed to it because it
invites the state into your life and uh
uh if I'm not mistaken I may be
misquoting but he said something along
the lines of I don't see any advantage
to it
um which is something I've talked about
in depth for years I have a chapter in
my book on why smart men don't marry so
I thought that was a little bit of a
deviation and Direction but I'm not sure
if that's um
that's a new strategy for image or what
that might be he was certainly the most
tame I've ever seen him in any interview
yeah there was no shirt off cigars
sunglasses
so you know and I think if you go back
to the other interview that he did with
I think the chick's name is chion or
something like that that [ __ ]
but he he even made a ploy to say look
I'm doing this on purpose I'm being over
the top on purpose I'm trying to piss
this chick off because it's funny and
I'm having a good time but at the same
time he's he's said these things and
he's embodied these things as well so
yeah I don't know I don't know if it's
sort of an image thing I don't know if
it's uh but then he went on pbd he went
on Patrick vets David Patrick Davis
podcast and it was kind of the same
things we've always heard so it was a
little interesting um and I don't know
if that's Network influence or if
they're like hey you you this shit's not
gonna fly you're gonna have to play by
our game which uh I don't think he's the
kind of guy that works I don't know if
there's like a new PR guy or a PR
Company but there's been a shift in uh
he's even said himself he's even said
himself right like part of the interview
was like look when I was saying these
things when I had 500 followers like I
didn't give it I never thought I was
gonna be the most famous man in the
world and now that I have five million
plus followers or however many I being
that I have this much influence it is
important for me to think about the way
that I say things
um and that's not to me that's not a
pacifier that's not pacifying the masses
that is understanding that there are Bad
actors out there that are dumb and will
take the information how they see fit so
don't give them any more reason to kind
of take things out of context at least
that's the way that I look at it yeah
what'd you think Jaren did you say it by
the way yeah I I didn't see the whole
thing I caught the first what like 10
minutes or so but you had to mirror a
lot what ma said
um I think one I don't really like those
types of formats like on the mainstream
news I don't feel like they're really
good interviewers if that makes sense
like for rich for changing the
conversation you have to water it down a
lot you do um like Rich when you
interview people you you give them the
floor you give them space you let them
talk you let them present their points
um a lot of times you don't even really
argue with them you just want to get the
information out there but everyone knows
kind of how Piers Morgan's style is when
he interviews it's confrontational yeah
he's this he's a tate but more
mainstream he does the same thing and I
I to be honest I watched the first 10
minutes and he wouldn't let Tate get a
freaking word out of his mouth so for me
the way I consume information I just I I
don't have the patience for that it was
like let the let the guy talk and it was
very reminiscent of Jordan Peterson's
interview with Kathy Newman and he did a
couple things exactly that but you're
saying that that chick the blonde chick
so that that's what it really it took me
back there yeah yeah like the um
there was a lot of time probably at
least half an hour uh you know a good
third of the conversation was was spent
over the whole comment about
saying that having a preference for
younger women is misogyny and
um absurd I mean I I mean I would have
talked about evil psych studies you know
just going it because like any time you
survey men from around the world doesn't
matter if they're 20 or 70 they all
universally I mean you have a lineup of
women from in from every age group guys
around the world culturally
cross-culturally every sort of aspect
always picks something like 22 to 23
year olds is the most attractive right
um
you know you have a preference for
beauty and youth being wrong it's just
it's just off the chart dude it's just
it's really difficult though is because
you would bring that up and say well I
don't care what the rest of the world
thinks I want to care about what you
think so it's tough when we want to
bring up examples and say look like it's
this is a fact this is the way the world
works like why don't care about the rest
of the world I care about you it's like
well that that's the difficulty so
that's why it kind of gets off track as
well because like I'm just interested in
what you're saying it's like well I have
to set the stage and set the table of
the way the world works and the way our
reality is for you to understand because
otherwise the thing that I say sound
crazy but that if I were to say you know
this besides the West this is what
everyone thinks
um I think our guy is also waiting in
the link by the way uh Matthew oh yeah
yeah there he is hold on so let's grab
this dude in person yeah on that point
one thing that I don't understand like
we literally have dudes we have dudes
out there lopping their dicks off and
saying it's okay and we're celebrating
transitions for teens in high school
which is completely unethical completely
immoral we've we've talked on it in the
one percent Forum like a lot of us know
people within our inner circles and our
families that are dealing with that
right now but then when a guy's like oh
yeah I like hot chicks that are young
for feminine and fertile it's like whoa
everyone loses their goddamn minds and
it is insane to me and I've never even
women have their preferences for height
money and looks and all that sort of
stuff but like that's the point I made
in a video I published earlier this week
is that women are allowed to have
preferences and they're never called me
sandras right if like I don't like short
guys or I like Rich guys or you have to
have a nice car I mean you never hear
anybody say well that's missandry but if
you express a preference for beauty and
youth and fertility then that's now
misogyny right but it's just the way
things are that's what I'm gonna get
like why do people why are people so
emotionally invested in who I'm
attracted to or who I'm sleeping with
like as long as I'm not sleeping with
you because it's about controlling
sleeping with yeah because it's about
controlling the narrative and
controlling men and the more you can
soften and weaken them and take away
their power and their preferences and
shame them for their preferences you
know for example the more control you
have over Society it's it's uh it's that
whole cycle of you know like Good Times
great weak men strong men create better
times blah blah blah sort of stuff so
which is fine that leaves more
attractive girls for me and MAF and Rich
I know you're in a relationship but you
know guys like us I I don't really care
but the fact again that people are so
emotionally invested in outraged in my
sexual preferences it blows my mind
because I could care less hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out